on est bien peu de choses et mon ami la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
à l'aurore je suis née
je me suis épanouie
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvelle
épisode du petit Emir la semaine
dernière nous avons découvert le métier
d'art thérapeute à travers le portrait
de Marika notre métier en scène
cette semaine nous allons nous
intéresser à la partie musicale du petit
ami avec raïs un musicien très
expérimenté c'est le bassiste de David
Sicard et ergothérapeute qui vient nous
rendre visite à la ressource dès que
raïs arrive Marika le présente à
Jean-Michel et Mathias c'est l'occasion
pour Jean-Michel de nous parler des
rapports entre la musique et l'univers
des malentendants par rapport à la
problématique des enfants de déficients
auditif donc ce qui est important c'est
effectivement eux fonctionnent avec les
vibrations donc si le sang est assez
fort ou
adapté pour que il semble des vibrations
ils peuvent très bien rentrer dans
dans la mélodie et pouvoir danser on
retrouve vraiment au même en boîte de
nuit des enfants sourds qui ont vraiment
une rythmique même au niveau des
percussions ils sont souvent très très
rythmées et très très habile
pour des apprentissages de son pour les
enfants de déficients auditifs on
utilise par exemple le bruit de verre
cassé
sur sur le la chaîne hi-fi et donc c'est
transmis par l'enceinte et on
essaie d'apprendre à l'enfant à détecter
à détecter le son juste donc tu as
plusieurs sons différents ça peut être
le klaxon d'une voiture ou un verre
cassé une porte qui se ferme enfin il y
a plusieurs sons comme ça et c'est un
apprentissage donc qu'utiliser un
surtout les orthophonistes les
audioprothéistes pour une rééducation de
l'oreille la musique c'est souvent une
histoire de rencontre aujourd'hui c'est
celle de raïs et Mathias dans la musique
en général là-bas c'est toujours le côté
un peu un peu tribal qui te fait un peu
danser c'est ça avec tout le côté
rythmique et
c'est vrai qu'on va essayer de s'en
rapprocher j'adore les grosses
ça tombe bien moi aussi tu vois il y a
des choses à construire autour de la
pièce et des morceaux des ambiances etc
bon on va essayer de faire au mieux
de mon côté
rice nous parle maintenant de sa passion
pour la musique et de sa collaboration à
venir sur le petit émir par le biais de
Marika dans ce cadre de ce projet-là
elle m'a interpellé parce qu'on se
connaît déjà depuis 2002 date à laquelle
Marika était embauché en fait au sein de
l'association et en tant que thérapeute
en fait donc maintenant elle est sur
davantage d'émission de coordination on
va dire des de l'ensemble des projets
artistiques sur l'aspha et du coup à ce
titre elle m'a interpellé pour voilà
participer un peu et voir de quelle
manière je pouvais apporter une ma
contribution on va dire au projet donc
voilà c'est à ce titre du coup que
j'interviens un peu dans le spectacle
qui est du coup pour moi un nouveau
challenge parce que
dans la distribution
on travaille cette fois avec le centre
de la ressource donc avec des des
niveaux de handicap qui sont un peu
différents de ceux avec lesquels
j'habitue de travailler
et ce qui va aussi du coup imposer des
nouvelles
nouvelles contraintes entre guillemets
dans le sens où il va falloir passer par
des choses un peu plus vibratoires
kinesthésique j'aurais presque envie de
dire ou
voilà il va falloir réfléchir à comment
trouver des ambiances sonores de la
musique qui fasse sens pour pour les
jeunes notamment déficients auditif et
puis voir aussi de quelle manière on
peut trouver des morceaux qui complètent
et qui qui embellissent surtout
la pièce initiale du petit Emir donc
voilà c'est un nouveau challenge donc
moi je suis complètement partant pour ce
nouveau projet
voilà vous en savez désormais un peu
plus sur la collaboration musicale sur
le petit Emir grâce à raïs la semaine
prochaine nous vous invitons à découvrir
le portrait de Nicolas afin de mieux
comprendre son handicap et sa manière de
le vivre à très bientôt donc